hey what's up my name is samuel leeds in
this video i want to talk to you about
mcdonald's
and how they make their money from real
estate they make their money from
property not from selling hamburgers and
fries now you may already know this you
may think yeah i've heard this before
i've heard that mcdonald's are actually
property developers and they make their
money from real estate but you just
don't know how it works what the
business
actually looks like maybe you didn't
know it maybe you thought that
mcdonald's actually made their money
from
selling food in which case you were
entirely wrong
and they are actually property
developers they are
real estate investors so i'm going to
explain in this video
exactly how that works what their
business model is
and how clever and smart their business
model is as well
hopefully it will inspire you it will
educate you but please do me a massive
favor
smash the like button i spend a lot of
time
researching things like this all around
property business investment i do a
youtube video every single day
so like the video and also don't forget
to subscribe
and turn the notification bell on so
mcdonald's what do they do i hope you
liked the video by the way
what they do is very very smart
they do not like most restaurants most
restaurants do this most restaurants
will buy a building okay they'll buy a
a a restaurant and then they'll move
into the restaurant
and then they'll sell food and drinks
and they'll make their money
from food and drinks and all that money
that they make they'll put towards
paying the mortgage or paying the rent
paying the bills and whatever's left is
profit and that is how most restaurants
make their money
simple they're in the restaurant
business they're in the food business
now some restaurants will lease their
buildings
and then they'll just pay the rent
others will own their buildings and
they'll pay the mortgage payments
just depends on the restaurant how cash
rich they are what mcdonald's do
is entirely different
what mcdonald's do is they
buy a piece of land and then they build
their buildings why do they do that why
do they build instead of buying an
existing restaurant well the reason that
they do that is because if you actually
look
at the mcdonald's buildings you can tell
i mean they look nice
from from going to have a quick
hamburger perspective
it's perfect but from a build point of
view
it's very cheap it's plasticky it's
bright
it's it's cheap they're not building
luxury restaurants they're not building
luxury homes
they're building a you know i don't like
to say cheap and tacky because it's not
tacky but i mean it's certainly
you know you wouldn't take your wife out
on a date would you to mcdonald's why
because it's it's plasticky it's cheap
so they
buy a piece of land probably cheap
because they're buying in bulk
they build these cheap plasticky
restaurants and then what they do is
instead of running it as a restaurant
they find
a franchisee so they find somebody
and they sell they sell the franchisee
on the idea of coming and being
a business owner that the franchisee
will come on
and they'll run the business and they'll
become mcdonald's but the franchisee
will pay mcdonald's what
not just royalties they'll pay them rent
and they only allow franchisees that can
fix the contract for 20
years so what does that do to the price
of the building
if they if they build a cheap little
mcdonald's building i don't know how
much it will cost
probably peanuts also have you seen how
fast they're constructed
suddenly let's just say woof overnight
there's a new mcdonald's it's not like
oh we're building this for six twelve
months it's just there
in three days it's because of how it's
built cheap
fast just like the food right cheap fast
so
they will then get a tenant a franchise
a franchisee
put them into the building and then the
tenant will start paying mcdonald's rent
now that's great from mcdonald's point
of view because effectively they've just
bought a really cheap building
and now got a really high paying tenant
fixed for 20 years
boom car ching but here's the real win
for mcdonald's
the real win is commercial properties
i.e a property that's used for for a
business or a restaurant
or offices the commercial buildings are
valued based on their
rent so the buildings
not only have they got rent coming in
now for 20 years but suddenly the value
of the building because of the rent is
pushed up so suddenly they've built this
little cheap
building so cheap restaurant mcdonald's
aren't responsible for the interiors
they don't kit it out they don't
maintain it
they just build the building in
three days or something and then whack a
tenant in over 20 years
the building shoots up in value so they
just got rich
but on top of the the equity they've
made in the building they've got a
tenant paying them for 20 years and
after 20 years what happens
the building has gone up in value even
more because mcdonald's know
that real estate holds its value more
than
cheeseburgers do and restaurants so
that's how they get rich now is what
they're doing ethical
sure it's ethical it's not unethical but
they're unashamed about it as well
they will tell you the ceos of
mcdonald's even ray crook the [ __ ] will
crook
ray kroc he's not a crook ray kroc um
says they're in the real estate business
and ray
ray kroc figured this out very early and
if you've not watched the movie
i would highly recommend watching the
mcdonald's movie it's called the founder
and ray crock's face when he realizes
that he's in the real estate business
is there a problem a big one you don't
seem to realize what business you're in
you're not in the burger business you're
in the real estate business
he takes over the business from the
brothers he scales it massive
they are turning over tens and tens of
billions of pounds every single year
and what you'll notice is a very tiny
percentage of that
of the profit for mcdonald's is coming
from food
also their buildings they don't
nearly all of them are they they
franchise them out 93
of mcdonald's so every time you drive
past the mcdonald's there's a 93
chance that that is not operated by
mcdonald's
it's operated by a franchisee it's still
mcdonald's but it's not the
it's not the mcdonald's owners and and
they're even disappointed they're like
we want it to be more
their goal is to have 95 percent of the
mcdonald's branches
operated by franchisees because they
have no interest in making money from
the food
they only have interest in making money
from the real estate because mcdonald's
know
that true wealth is in real
estate and it's so interesting that a
lot of other companies that you might
think
are making their money in one way i've
got a really good friend of mine
who um he's in the car business and he's
a billionaire
and he sells cars very very very
successful
and after having a conversation with him
guess what he said that 80
of his wealth is also in real estate
it's incredible
you do not realize this until you start
following the money and digging so
i hope you found this video helpful if
you want to learn more about real estate
and how you can make money in real
estate then i do run free
property investment education courses
i'll leave a link
in the description below and i hope to
see you in person
where i can help you set up your own
real estate company even if you're
starting with very very little money
like if you watch the movie uh ray ray
kroc started with very very little money
but
it was how he was smart and how he knew
how to negotiate a deal which is what
made him successful and guess what i did
the same thing too
not on his level but i'm a
multi-millionaire and you can do the
same thing as well
hit the link in the description let's
get started thanks for watching the
video
i'll see you next time